hey little guys my name is Regina
welcome back to my opengl series so at
last time which was quite a while ago we
talked about setting out a test
framework when we did set up a test
framework and we actually implemented a
clear color test you guys haven't seen
that video is up there in the top right
corner I will reiterate a little bit
about why we're doing this and where
this series is going just because I feel
like it's been I think actually has been
like three months since the last I can't
yell episode and I am sorry about that
we're gonna try and be more consistent
from now on so the purpose of what we're
doing right now in the OpenGL series is
and the reason why I kind of dive over
the series to actually set up this test
framework is because as we start
introducing new concepts and you kind of
you already know all the basics I mean
we haven't covered absolutely every kind
of what I would consider an OpenGL kind
of foundational thing right like you
know we're probably textures we've got
vertex buffers we've got FedEx race
there's still some things we haven't
covered like for example we haven't
coated frame buffers yet so we haven't
covered absolutely every kind of
foundational OpenGL really missing a
word here um pillar let's say pillar
every kind of tool I guess that OpenGL
gives us in order to actually achieve
some kind of rendering task right we
haven't learned about all of them yet
but we have learned about most of them
and we have this stuff that we've
learned so far you there is actually
quite a lot of things you could do right
and even there's very very simple API
that we've constructed is enough to do
so many things right so now that we've
kind of learned about the basics of all
of all of these different things that we
can do what I want to do is separate
everything that we've learned out into
tests that we can kind of switch between
them but and basically about what a test
is again what definitely watch the test
framework video if you haven't already
but it's actually just like almost like
an isolated application it's just that
instead of kind of actually making an
application or a separate like video
studio projects to separate separate
kind of executable program for each test
for each technique if you will that
we've learned because that would be just
really annoying to kind of go through
all of them you have two lon
to launch like separate applications
every time and that's just a mess right
I want to just have one application
which is like our sandbox essentially or
a test like application right and then I
want to have a menu there where you can
kind of just switch between all the
stuff that we've done really easily
right that's the whole goal of this and
at the end of the day if so that you can
open up a single source file for like
clear color and because that's the only
one we've done right now and just look
at what you actually need to do to
implement that right and of course when
we do get into more advanced techniques
like lighting or shadow mapping or
something like that you know or like if
you want to render your scene into a
texture and then display it or do like
post-processing on it whatever right you
can just open up the post effects test
or something and just look at the code
and you're like okay this is how I
render to a texture and this is how I
apply a blur pass over trick or
something like that right the idea is to
make everything really simple to read
because at the end of day that's what we
want we want like a library of
techniques that we can just show off in
the simplest way possible and that's why
I've set up this test framework okay
enough reiteration what I'm going to do
now is actually continue on with that
and implement the because what we
actually did is when we created this
test framework we had you know some
geometry rendering like with the channel
logo just like this there quad on the
spring with the Shona logo but we
deleted all that code because we want to
clear our application doors if EP file
and actually make make it just about the
tests so now we're going to write a test
which basically shows how to render a
texture and it's gonna be pretty quick
because we've already written the code
before that's what we're going to do
today and the next time we're gonna
hopefully move on to batch rendering
because now that we have this test
framework I feel comfortable enough to
actually say okay we'll make a new test
called bet rendering and then a lot to
show off how to actually render you know
a bunch of calls at once like in a batch
okay so that's the plan let's dive into
the code so the first thing we really
need to do is of course I've got test
clear color open over here we have our
test or H which sure is kind of you know
everything we need to know about the
actual test framework here but if we
look at test PayPal does really up test
that's our basic test so what we can do
is actually copy and paste that
what I like to do that is just to open
the containing folder for this stuff and
then just copy and paste both of these
files and then I'm just going to rename
test click color to test text chunk or
something like that yeah I think the
test text remove test texture to do or
someone backs we will have more advanced
text your tests in the future
and then if I go over here I can just
click on the test folder hit this little
refresh button and then include both of
these in my project as simple as that
in the header file I'm going to change
test player colleges test texture 2d and
of course I'll replace the this is great
I'll replace the constructor and
destructor with that and women we don't
need this click all the privates so I
will just get rid of that for now and
then if I alts or into this using visual
assist to get to be super big file I
will change this to test texture um and
then yeah we can keep this stuff and
then I'll just do it if I hit ctrl
ashing into a find/replace for a test
clear color into test texture 2d and all
hard to replace everything in this
document ok cool done so that's pretty
much it we've got a blank canvas I guess
for actually writing our tests yeah I
will probably keep setting the clear
color to like you know black or
something like that um and I'll click
the clear in there and then of course I
don't need anything for the iron giving
stuff just yet ok so there we go we have
a blank test it's probably even nice it
would probably even be nice to just
create a blank test kind of file or you
can even set up visual studio like a
template or something like that if you
really want to I never doing it's not
bad I just copy and paste files and then
kind of a factor than just rename
stuff in them using finer place like I
just did then but essentially now we
have a blank file start off with so now
let's write the code that we need to
actually display a texture um now I
could write all the code from scratch
it's actually pretty simple but doesn't
even easier way of course I did have it
written at one point
I just go to the github repository for
this project which by the way you can
access if you become a patron by going
to petrol knock on four slash at the
Cherno you'll get access to all this
kind of github source code which is
great because it goes kind of episode by
episode and also helps support this
series as well we have all the commits
from this entire from each episode as
separate commits so if I just go to the
one where I set up a test framework and
just go to that specific diff for that
um for that commit I can also browse the
repository at that point but this might
be easier if I look at application I can
see all the credit removed which was
basically out our texture rendering test
right so I can just copy and paste this
stuff back into my visual jr. and it
should work so let's start with all this
kind of position and indices stuff and
in fact you know what I might just go
and get pretty much everything just like
that we will have to bring it up we will
have to bring some things out into
members because they need to survive
more than just a construction scope
obviously but some of these things like
flight positions don't need to actually
exist for longer than this scope because
as soon as we add them to our actual
vertex buffer like that's it they're
done okay so for over here in the
constructor I'm just going to paste in
old our code and let's take a look at
what we need to change here so positions
can stay and actually it controls
they're just so maintains the formatting
good
okay so positions caused a you know
indices can stay blend and stuff like
that can stay we should have some kind
of state probably that gets reset every
time because obviously one of these
tests enables blending we don't want to
have to disable blending you know like
at the end of this test essentially so
that might be a problem when you might
need to solve any wave etics arrays here
we'll definitely need to bring that out
that is love for as well lay up and stay
I don't know why that's an error or
incomplete type okay we need to include
some of these things of course so let's
include one city X buffer that okay
better layouts probably sign thing okay
it's not a layout GLM which I have no
include four that is actually if we go
back to here think it we've been at the
top
whoops less clothing on the file and we
see it yeah let's just open the file I
just had the thing oh okay that was
enough in the file fantastic I just go
back here and we go to this we can look
at the file actually that's after I
removed everything but anyway inches so
video yep there it is and if we go back
here we can just include GLM and yeah
that's that's like pretty much it except
the texture kind of important to the
texture test so one quick texture yeah
and then that's pretty much it so we put
everything we need here obviously we
need to set everything up for rendering
so things that we actually would need
for the rendering loop if you look at
this exact code here and we had like
translations and so that as well set out
but what we really just need is the
shadow the renderer object which of
course I think is just passed in to the
render function or no it's not actually
so we need to get that from somewhere
render it yeah it's what we really need
a thing right we didn't set that up so
this is why when I just once a while
between videos don't forget what
actually exists no we don't have that
okay so that's interesting but I mean
all that really is is it's like let me
just create a render object for now and
tell it what to do if we need to because
it's just literally like the renderer
right now is just doesn't need to be
like static or anything it's just a it's
just a set of commands that don't apply
or any kind of State what I mean by that
is like the render doesn't have like you
know any kind of member variables or
anything so you can just create a
rendering instance per frame essentially
that'll be like free right because it's
just a stack object that has no size if
it's got the size of one it's got
nothing in it and then you can just call
the draw command because really at this
point draw is almost like a
free-floating function it just happens
to be inside the renderer class it could
just be static
anyway so back over here yeah I guess
I'll copy most of this we have all these
sliders and stuff right on that we had
before and the frame rate so let's just
copy that from my own GUI and then we
can put it and then we can put it into
on iron grandeur which is over here and
then as for this stuff I don't work
increment is we probably don't need that
I think that's a good color
we'll grab this rendering code that we
have and just put it into on render at
the end here
and then I think that's pretty much all
we need yeah translation is that okay
good so then we can just start actually
sorting this code out because I think
we've got a little bit here now so
translation a transaction be those would
just what even others we did we make
them here they are they're just chilling
back threes so if we go back to here
we'll make we'll make them here so em
translation a and B here this will set
them up in a constructor let me get them
again
so we'll say I'm translation a is 200
200 0 and translation babe is 400 200 0
ok that's set up what else did we need
in here so we need a shader of course
this becomes M translation a this
becomes M translation of B and let's
sell the shader okay so the renderer we
can just as I said just to make it like
this that's totally fine we only need it
to actually cool this and that's it so
we need the vertex array we need the
index ball phone we need the shader so
pretty easy let's actually go up here
and we might as well just include this
stuff I think here now we also need the
texture so vertex array um I'll call it
the air we needed vertex buffer what we
don't need the buff up well we're
definitely index buffer what do we
actually need ok shader yeah we do need
an X bar phone so index buffer em I'm Bo
or just say index buffer so whatever
text array but our index buffer when you
have shader and let's go back up here
and replace everything sir shade it
becomes that so let's just go up and
initialize it here cherchez de is this
index buffer is in season six evangelize
that later we might need to actually
make these you know what I did make them
stack variables but I'm regretting this
already
we'll just make them unique pointers and
that will be the end of that so this is
probably the first time you know saying
China use smart pointers but it's victor
pretty because that's the right thing to
do in this case well the memory so that
we get access to all these my point is
and we will make full of these unique
pointers because having a mistake for
apples is kind of unnecessary and we
don't really want to do it that way okay
so now we can get rid of this and
actually yeah you can there's a few ways
you could just make unique but you don't
have to that's just there to be
consistent with the API but I guess I
will still use it so as to be make
unique and then we'll do the same thing
for the FedEx array and var pickles no
that was helping me yep
make unique I'm an index buffer as well
and then for the index buffer which
happens there we will make it here and
we'll take the arguments and put medium
that x-ray on buffer becomes via our and
buffer
shada of course is now different as well
and we've already made it so we just
have to do shade of bind uniform
textures well we need to bring out in a
minute and yeah we don't really need to
unbind anything okay so text shot let's
bring up texture as well
this v8 pointer text row and then we'll
take the texture
nest DD make unique texture we don't
need to find it yet would you need to
bind it yeah they're um so we'll do
texture bind this shader bind so I guess
the renderer doesn't find the shader
well maybe does it does so we don't need
to find the shader that's because we
need to set the uniform yeah okay so
we've always loved to do that set
uniform yeah the project view is not a
thing so let's find those quickly here
they are
well Padma yeah projection matrix you
could of course store as a let's change
let's store that as a member
actually here they are here so robably
yeah why we had to meet ah that was the
original code my bad
okay so and view view is set to that I
get great so let's actually move this
out
GLM for and proj and phew
so now if we scroll up we can just get
rid of that we call that progeny you and
then over here and proj M here M var
which we I think we'll have to do right
dereference m index buffer which will
also dereference and M shadow also
dereference because this takes in
references I think yes ok great
and then this is the same and proj and
view share to bind and that becomes
whoops becomes m shader it's been so
long I'm um I'm just struggling to type
on this love 12 because I'm really not
used to this okay
never go I think that's perfect now on a
post translation I am Katie on members
now so we do that Wow
okay I think that's good I should look
over this card and see if it what's
let's maybe bring this shader down to
where it's actually used I should look
for this pair make sure works but I'm
just gonna leave it like this because
yes yeah with this as well and brought
in view I guess I could make them up
here
because that way they wouldn't need to
be initialized twice so proj is that you
is that I'll definitely move this stuff
down okay there we go so that's
everything
let's build everything on see if it
compiles I know this episode might seem
a little bit boring or just like you
know just doing stuff and not like
talking about it maybe but like this is
just working things to get done and I
think the depth of the problem and I end
up looking more like this anyway because
as we actually stop talking about stuff
and start writing code based on stuff we
already know that can make quite a
mundane task so anyway it is what it is
okay so this is succeeded let's actually
see if this works
obviously we haven't used the test
anyway so we definitely need to do that
first so the good application all we
really need to do is we create our test
menu and we just need to once we have
that test menu we can register our tests
so we have clear color as a test here
I'm just going to copy and paste that so
that it becomes test texture 2d and then
if I go here this is this becomes test
texture 2d texture 2d well I'll say 2d
texture and I think that's actually what
we need that one line of code in our
test framework is enough to do
everything so let's just run and say
here see if this run won't be surprised
if this doesn't crash to be honest
because yeah okay 2d texture okay there
we go
we crashed fantastics on these null I
believe and it's in OpenGL okay so this
is this might be a hard error to debug
let's go back to let's change that
thread to our main thread so we can look
at what's actually happening so
something's null that's interesting it's
not happy with something whoa I mean
talks about the same is correct and our
maybe have etics raise roam but yeah
that's definitely interesting so this is
throwing a null pointer exception inside
the graphics driver
I believe what's the output yeah okay so
that's fantastic hmm I wonder what
that's caused that let's look it out
texture today test that's what I'm
showing up yet okay where is it sir
[Music]
well this stuff okay so it's just the of
course it's because I've added but has
been deleted so here the way that we
talk about those buffers is that this
the scope of the sexual class is the
scope of the bed next buffer because you
can see in the destructor we delete it
so that's what's happened um it's trying
to run from about as well if it's now
been deleted that's why the graphics
driver crashes so to fix that of course
what we need to do is actually on the
CPU side maintain our betting but for
some reason I thought but once we there
is another design of course that you
could have done which is where instead
of doing well this you could just kind
of have your CPU cycle your vertex
buffer class is just like a little kind
of wrapper class almost that just sends
data to the GPU and that's all you need
it for and then you can discard it once
the dog is on the GPU but of course we
haven't done it that way because doing
it that way it requires a different
handle maintenance kind of system right
because obviously we still need to
retain that renderer handle so we
basically have a one-to-one mapping
between CPU side objects and GPU side
objects what I mean by that is that I
have my vs. buffer object on the CPU it
is a mirror of what's on the GPU right
once it gets created the GPU allocates
memory once it gets deleted the GPU
deallocate memory right it's just one to
one mapping so if we do something like
this where we make it on the stack
inside the constructor once we reach
down in the scope it gets deleted and
then our vertex buffer actually gets
removed from GPU memory which is bad if
we're trying to then render to it so I'm
actually kind of glad this arrow
happened because it gave me a chance to
talk about this not even think about it
to be honest
so M vertex buffer equals this and then
we just need to come over here and that
should be it
okay what is wrong with you already - no
that's fine oh yeah what's wrong with
that about the UM I forgot the angular
bracket okay so a buffer of course okay
Sam better I feel like that dereferenced
and yeah let's hit a fight again in her
please what okay so 2d texture okay look
at that and then we've got our two
things being rendered actually well add
multiple times and this is all good it
looks like these two a links turn on a
translation a and B yeah what am I done
let's go back here that's funny
I think I I think I know what I did so
it's good yeah translate I've got
translation eight twice and that's what
was wrong okay so now we should be able
to control them independently so 2d
texture and then he has this one here's
this one yeah fantastic okay cool so
there we go um that is our test if we go
back and deletes everything and plays
everything and then we can go back and
click oh we can't go back when you go to
the texture we can go back and you can
see how like every time essentially it
will kind of create them and destroy
them and we actually have like a texture
test now as well as like a rendering
multiple objects test and then we have a
quick hold test as well and I guess the
point of all this is that if you lose
code is less than 100 lines and it's
sort of like concise right like is in
its got like just everything we need
really like this is everything you need
to kind of create the shader create the
vertex array object right the next
buffer correct the version spot for the
vertex layout everything that I need to
set up those two objects and the texture
obviously and everything
that where's the texture we can even
kind of divide this a bit to make it
even more clear so I might even group
this kind of stuff like that because
it's kind of creating dividers array and
everything then we have our index buffer
and when we actually say okay it didn't
ever get set in the constructor and then
we have kind of shader and then the
texture and everything is kind of
grouped and really easy to use because
they're really unique pointers they will
get destroyed at the end of the scope so
we don't even have to write anything in
a disrupter because we've you know if
you smart pointers kind of correctly
yeah I made a video last week for the
city of los series about safety and like
about whether or not you should use
smart pointers and what my opinions are
on that and and how that kind of comes
into teaching C++ so watch that video if
you claim it if you're more interested
and what I mean by all this stuff
because I don't know how but I seem to
have built up some kind of a reputation
that I don't use smart pointers I do
it's just that I don't think that I
don't think that roll pointers should be
banned because there are a lot of uses
for them in fact I've used them in the
test menu of this but obviously for
something like this when I have a class
and I just need heat kind of allocating
memory to survive for the duration of
that class kind of like lifetime then of
course I'm gonna use unique point is
they are zero cost basically they are
zero cost will say and they're you know
they're just they make programming so
much easier so anyway but yeah they'll
get delayed over matically on update
with any new things we wanted to animate
stuff we could have that here and then
on render you know destroys okay here
I'm rendering one entrepreneuring the
other object you could annotate this
with comments if you wanted to and then
we have 2000 debug pass which is kind of
just where we can render any kind of UI
that we wanted manipulate stuff and it's
just so clean and so easy so that's kind
of point of all this and of course as
always the source code will be on github
if you want to take a look at it I hope
you guys know this video if you did even
hit that like button as I said access to
source to source code and also helping
to support this series can be done by
going to patron of all slash the Cherno
and you'll get heaps of other awards as
well so doesn't have monthly hangouts
with me
and like access to like a patron only
kind of chat on this board it fits us up
there and it really does have sports
seriese so as always thank you so much
those patrons for making this possible
next time we're gonna finally get into
the batch render I can't wait I've been
itching to do that for months I will see
you next time goodbye